en este vídeo vamos a tratar de calcular
a que es igual un medio más un tercio y
como siempre los invito a pausar el
vídeo y tratar de resolver esto por su
cuenta vamos a resolver esto juntos y
puede ser útil visualizar un medio y un
tercio esta es una imagen de un medio si
vemos esta barra como un entero sombre
amos la mitad de esta y si queremos
visualizar un tercio luce así así que
podemos ver esto como un medio más este
tercio gris aquí a que será igual esto
es algo difícil sabemos cómo sumar si
tenemos el mismo denominador así que si
tuviéramos cierto número de mitades aquí
y cierto número de mitades acá entonces
podríamos saber cuántas mitades tenemos
aquí pero aquí vamos a tratar de sumar
mitades y tercios como hacemos eso bueno
tratamos de encontrar un común
denominador ahora que quiero decir con
común denominador bueno es expresar esta
cantidad y esta cantidad en términos de
otro denominador y una buena forma de
pensar
esto es que existe un múltiplo de 2 y 3
lo más sencillo es usar el mínimo común
múltiplo que en el caso de 2 y 3 es 6
entonces podemos expresar un medio en
términos de sextos y un tercio en
términos de sextos vamos a comenzar con
1 entre 2 y voy a hacer esta barra de
fracción un poco más grande en un
momento veremos por qué bueno si
queremos expresar esto en términos de
sextos para ir de medios a sextos
tenemos que multiplicar el denominador
por 3 pero si queremos multiplicar el
denominador por 3 y no cambiar el valor
de la fracción tenemos que multiplicar
el numerador por 3 también y para ver
por qué esto tiene sentido piensen en
esto esto que está en verde es
exactamente lo que teníamos antes pero
ahora al multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por 3 hemos expresado esto
en sextos noten que la barra está
dividida en 6 y en la parte verde que
podemos ver como el numerador ahora
tenemos 3
así que ahora estos son sextos tenemos
tres sextos en lugar de un medio esto es
lo mismo que tres entre seis y queremos
sumar esto a que bueno como expresamos
un tercio en términos de sextos la forma
en la que podemos hacer esto es tomar
este uno entre tres y cada uno de estos
tercios dividirlo en dos secciones así
que para pasar de tercios a sextos vamos
a multiplicar el denominador por 2 y
también multiplicaremos el numerador por
2 y para ver porque esto tiene sentido
noten que esta parte gris es exactamente
lo que tenemos aquí pero ahora tomamos
cada una de estas secciones y la
dividimos en dos secciones multiplicamos
el numerador y el denominador por 2 en
lugar de tercios en lugar de tres
secciones iguales ahora tenemos seis
secciones iguales esto es el resultado
de multiplicar el denominador por dos en
lugar de sombrear sólo uno de ellos
ahora son veamos dos de ellos porque una
de las cosas que sombreados se ha
transformado en dos secciones esto es
por multiplicar el numerador por 2 esto
es lo mismo que 3 sextos más esto que es
dos sextos como podemos ver aquí un
sexto dos sextos y ahora que todo está
en términos de sextos que será igual
bueno pues esto va a ser cierto número
de sextos
si tenemos tres de algo más dos de ese
algo pues vamos a tener cinco veces algo
y en este caso el algo son sextos esto
va a ser cinco sextos y pueden verlo por
aquí estos son tres de estos sextos uno
dos tres más dos de estos sextos 1 2 nos
da 5 sextos pero podemos ver también
como que esta parte verde era
originalmente un medio y esta parte gris
era un tercio pero pudimos calcularlo al
expresar ambos de ellos en sextos